welcome back to age 20 special
relativity in this section and also the
next one we want to make a case against
ether ether was presumed to be the
medium in which light traveled
we do this we make this case by studying
the michael smalling experiment
michaelson and molly went out to detect
the motion of the earth relative to
ether
and by not finding a result we can
conclude that at least in this form
ether doesn't exist
all right so what is the experimental
setup um also it's shown on the pictures
above
um we have a light source
here um from which the light travels to
some mirror which reflects about half
the light the half the light goes
through
reflected on the second mirror and then
comes to screen
the other part of the light is up and
back down
so the light either travels
against the ether wind or perpendicular
to the e7
if
ether is the medium in which light
travels then the velocity
needs to change the velocity of light in
this ether and this medium will change
if there is no e7 there is no change in
the velocity of the mind
the result of the experiment is an
interference pattern on the screen
so the experiment is called
and deform
so
there's some
systematic uncertainties here there's
some
unknowns for example uh if you're
building your table it's not really
clear in which direction either actually
which direction or is actually the
direction of the ease of flow but you
can
get by this by rotating the table and
making various sets of experiments and
that's what michaelson did
i want you to show
that the effect
they're about to observe or they will
not observe is of the order of v over c
square
and you have what you want to do is
compare the light
um the light as it travels
on this path number one to one mirror
and on the second pass to the second
mirror
so if you're following the video i ask
you to just stop here and figure out how
long does it take for the lights to
travel
on this path here on the lower path of
number one
or path number two
so obviously i've worked this out
already so we want to calculate the time
it takes light to travel
past one and that is you know going up
and coming down uh going left and going
right
so in the first case the velocity is
reduced by the velocity of insert so the
time it takes is
l1 the lag divided by c minus v
plus
return lag
l1 over
c plus b
when you rough this out and you simplify
a little bit you get this
first equation
for the second pass the one up and down
um you want to draw this this triangle
here to figure out that t is equal the
time it takes is equal to
the square root l square over c square
minus v squared and then you simplify
again we get this
form
with the square root again
what's important is the time difference
for the lights traveling with two legs
and you find that the time difference t1
at t2 minus t1 is given by this little
bit complicated looking equation
so now in the experiment you want to set
up l1 equal to l2 to simplify but you
might not be able to do it very
precisely what you can do however is
rotate the table if you rotate and then
compare the difference of the
differences you find that here
there's this
v square over c square dependency
i used a little trick to
simplify the square root as i use
this one plus or minus x to the nth
power is
about one plus minus n times x for x
very small and since the velocity of
ether is presumed to be small compares
to the speed of light that's when good
after the capability
the result of the experiment was there
was more effect they tried they improved
the experiment they tried to find
smaller effects i didn't find anything
the reason for this is
that there's no ether yes but we can use
this now to make a case against the user
but you could say that maybe they didn't
observe anything because the ether is
dragged with zeros so instead of
you know the earth going through this
ether and therefore the experience of
wind
you could argue that maybe esa is
localized around earth
moving with zeros or maybe we are living
in the universe
and so in the next video we'll look at a
case against that scenario
you